Precisamente en Washington hogar del
tribunal de supremo del país Allí está
nuestro corresponsal de Cristóbal
Vázquez con las dos noticias que hoy
atañen a este órgano una sobre el
expresidente Donald Trump y otra sobre
los derechos de las mujeres Cristóbal
buenas noches para usted Donald Trump le
pidió a la corte que intervenga en el
caso de Mara lago cuéntenos de esta
noticia
sí le pidió específicamente a la Corte
Suprema de Justicia de Estados Unidos
que empezó la sesión de invierno ayer
precisamente que le permita a el
encargado especial de la revisión de los
documentos que fueron allanados en su
mansión de Lago en la Florida que pueda
revisar 100 documentos que fueron
confiscados precisamente de la mansión y
que son catalogados como confidenciales
con esto lo que dice el expertos legales
Es que la expresidente del ex presidente
Donald Trump Busca demorar el proceso
esto precisamente porque hace unos días
una corte de apelaciones pues tumbó la
posibilidad de que no se pudiera usar
este contenido que fue allanado que fue
rescatado de la mansión de Mara lago en
contra de el ex presidente en contra de
la investigación Precisamente en esta
investigación que se adelanta por que el
expresidente se llevó de la Casa Blanca
documentos confidenciales es de Resaltar
sin embargo que el corte conservador en
el en el en el en el máximo órgano
legislativo de Estados Unidos como es la
Corte Suprema este corte conservador es
decir hay que recordar que Donald Trump
hizo elegir a tres magistrados de la
Corte Suprema durante sus últimos donde
durante su última administración esto le
da cierta ventaja sin embargo el
presidente está en su contra ya Donald
Trump había solicitado ciertas
interferencias precisamente de la Corte
Suprema de Justicia a favor de él pero
la corte a pues
ha dado órdenes en contra de el ex
presidente y de que él y de que la corte
termina interfiriendo a favor de los
procesos que se adelantan en contra de
Donald Trump y el otro tema Es que hoy
se cumplen 100 días de la caída de robby
way de y Joe biden habló sobre el tema
Cuál es el panorama en el país para el
aborto
sí varias cifras la primera es que el
65% de los estadounidenses en una
encuesta que se hace en julio pues
piensa que la decisión de la Corte
Suprema de Justicia fue errada y
decisión Que obviamente ya no reconoce
como derecho constitucional el aborto a
nivel Federal en Estados Unidos la otra
cifra es que ya precisamente después de
esta decisión de cumplirse 100 días de
la decisión de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia pues ya 13 estados han
prohibido el aborto en cualquier
circunstancia y muchos más pues han
limitado han restringido el aborto como
último le doy una cifra que es bastante
alarmante 43 clínicas de aborto han
cerrado en apenas tres estados donde se
ha prohibido el aborto en Estados Unidos
y esto ha hecho Obviamente que muchas
personas hayan tenido que emigrar y
estén migrando a otros estados para
poder hacer y para y poder abortar en
caso de que lo quieran hacer